bueno
ah
[Música]
continuamos en este cubrimiento especial
de la novena cumbre de las américas
desde la ciudad de los ángeles y para
continuar con este cubrimiento me hace
un espacio en su agenda el canciller de
ecuador juan carlos holguín muchas
gracias por este espacio para france24 y
bienvenidos a nuestra audiencia
muchísimas gracias un saludo a todos los
televidentes de france 24
bueno empiezo por preguntarle un anuncio
que llegó recientemente que es la
ecuador hace ahora parte del consejo
permanente de seguridad de la onu este
logro es por supuesto suyo y cuéntenos
qué va a ser ecuador desde ahí en un
logro del país estamos contentos tuvimos
190 votos de los 192 votantes que
estuvieron ayer en la asamblea de
naciones unidas es un compromiso
importante en este contexto mundial en
medio de un conflicto bélico y sobre
todo en una necesidad del mundo de tener
paz salimos de una pandemia y realmente
es absurdo haber caído en un ataque como
el que rusia
y procedió a cometer en ucrania y el
mundo necesita hoy que estemos en paz
que estemos con tranquilidad
esa va a ser la visión del ecuador
coherente con sus principios
tradicionales de creencia firme en el
multilateralismo y sobre todo en que
cualquier resolución de conflicto tiene
que darse precisamente allí en el
consejo de seguridad y en naciones
unidas con el diálogo con las vías
diplomáticas y representando a el grupo
de américa latina y el caribe queremos
también que haya paz en la región
tenemos ahora nuevas amenazas de
amenazas no convencionales sobre todo la
lucha contra las estructuras criminales
transnacionales que tienen que tener un
abordaje
también desde ese centro de la paz
mundial y canciller precisamente puede
ser este una forma de la comunidad
internacional de acercarse más a américa
latina en medio de este contexto que
usted menciona de la invasión rusa y
ucrania ese es el reto porque más allá
del consejo de seguridad y lo que se
discute en naciones unidas de hecho en
esta cumbre creo que todos hemos logrado
coincidir en que el continente tiene una
necesidad imperiosa por ejemplo ahora
frente a los desafíos de la seguridad
alimentaria el continente unido puede
ser un gran productor del mundo frente a
la gran crisis
alimentaria que va a existir fruto del
conflicto
productos que escasean hoy y que podrían
ser aprovechados en nuestro hemisferio y
creo que la mirada del mundo tiene que
estar en américa latina en los próximos
años bueno y en el marco de este cumbre
el presidente de joe biden hizo algunos
anuncios en materia migratoria que van a
estar incluidos en esta declaración de
los ángeles que nos pueden adelantar de
la declaración de los años en materia
migratoria la migración para para
ecuador primero es un tema muy
importante ecuador ha tenido una
vocación migratoria primero de
ciudadanos que desde la leca de los
sesentas de los 70 salieron precisamente
eeuu luego a principios de este siglo
tuvimos una gran presencia de
ecuatorianos en europa pero en los
últimos años hemos recibido
cientos de miles de hermanos venezolanos
que han llegado a nuestro país y esa
vocación migratoria nos ha hecho generar
el primer plan de regularización en
nuestro país lo lanzó el presidente lazo
hace 10 días aproximadamente junto con
el banco mundial canadá el sistema de
naciones unidas
que busca dar una condición estable
responsable de migración sobre todo
regular y segura a estos ciudadanos
venezolanos que requieren vincularse a
la sociedad por eso nosotros hemos
tomado con mucha atención lo que se ha
discutido aquí en migración pero hay una
realidad
eeuu sobre todo ha propuesto una
política pública hacia la migración de
manera muy general nosotros que pedimos
que haya un trabajo más bien de
desarrollo de oportunidades de nuestra
región para que los jóvenes no tengan
que salir a migrar en otro lugar ayer lo
decía el el presidente de panamá nadie
quiere salir de su país y para ello lo
conveniente es que tengamos un nuevo
marco económico sobre todo con la
coherencia y la solidaridad de eeuu para
poder tener oportunidades de nuestra
regional es decir que eeuu invierta y se
comprometa a invertir a través de sus
empresas en esta declaración final en
los países de suramérica y centroamérica
totalmente tener un gran bloque
económico porque la solución a la
migración pasa por el desarrollo
económico eso es al menos el criterio
del presidente lazo el criterio de
ecuador el tener un gran bloque
económico continental que pueda tener un
comercio fluido entre todos nosotros
y un comercio fluido genera más
oportunidades y sobre todo más dinero en
las familias de la región hay un punto
también de reasentamiento de refugiados
puede adelantarnos de qué se trata esto
pero nosotros hemos sido también un país
que recibió decenas de miles de
colombianos que fueron desplazados del
conflicto en su momento en nuestro país
vecino y ahora estamos viviendo lo mismo
con venezuela es lo que lo que yo
mencionaba y luego
fruto de lo que está pasando en el mundo
también una discusión acá de la de la
posibilidad de que tengamos nosotros
refugiados en nuestros países y ecuador
lo adoptara como digo nosotros tenemos
una gran posibilidad de poder tener una
vocación solidaria hacia la migración y
eso es parte de lo que estamos haciendo
va a recibir entonces de ecuador-
personas que solicitan refugio en eeuu
estamos en esa discusión hoy será un
gran día para discutir precisamente
aquello pero por ejemplo nosotros ya
estamos recibiendo refugiados
ucranianos en nuestro país y creemos que
es importante discutirlo
bueno y que otras cosas nos puede
adelantar de esta declaración final de
los ángeles
esperamos nosotros que más allá de
migración que más allá de los temas de
salud que han sido importantes discutir
los existe esta discusión sobre los
temas económicos y esperamos que al
menos si no está en una declaración
final este como parte de la agenda del
último día está discusión sobre la
creación de un nuevo marco de
cooperación que como lo ha dicho el
mismo presidente de byd en nazca del sur
hacia el norte del medio hacia los lados
y nos permita tener desarrollo
productivo económico crecimiento en cada
uno de nuestros países cancillería en
cuanto a la lucha contra el crimen
organizado transnacional que se ha
pactado en materia de luchar contra el
crimen así en colombia venezuela
paraguay hemos visto redes últimamente
con varios atentados varios sucesos que
incluso ha sucedido en las cárceles de
ecuador'
lo que dijo ayer el presidente mario
abdo de paraguay en la lucha contra las
estructuras criminales transnacionales
sólo puede ser abordada desde una óptica
transnacional y para ello es importante
la unidad ecuador también trae el
mensaje hoy lo mencionara el presidente
lazo en su disertación en la cumbre la
importancia de que exista una política
integral de defensa y seguridad para la
región puesto que esta lucha contra los
cárteles del narcotráfico que tanto daño
hace a nuestros niños a nuestros jóvenes
pero no sólo en la región sino también
acá donde hay mucho consumo a dónde
llega como punto final de destino la
droga o también otros actos criminales
como el tráfico y trata de personas que
llegan a la frontera en una condición de
inmigración riesgosa son industrias
enormes que están siendo consolidadas
por estas estructuras transnacionales
que requieren una respuesta integral y
de todos y está contenida esta respuesta
integral y de todos en la declaración
final no está no está contenida todavía
pero me alegra haber escuchado a varios
jefes de estado en la misma línea de
pedir al menos una solución y una
atención inmediata a este problema pero
si hay adelantos de ecuador- trabajando
con israel en ese sentido totalmente de
seguridad totalmente ecuador trabajando
con israel de manera directa en una
cooperación bilateral sobre todo para
fortalecer las capacidades de nuestras
fuerzas públicas y también con eeuu
también con colombia hace hace pocas
semanas pudimos en un operativo conjunto
con información tripartita de eeuu colom
y ecuador- desarticular una de las
bandas más importantes del narcotráfico
en el ecuador sobre todo un primer golpe
a la estructura de financiamiento una
incautación in situ de más de 26
millones de dólares entre lingotes de
oro y dinero en efectivo que tenía un
narcotraficante ecuatoriano canciller y
quien está operando desde las cárceles
de ecuador son los cárteles del
narcotráfico indudablemente esa lucha
entre cárteles se movió a los centros
penitenciarios que hace un año cuando el
presidente lanzó diego al gobierno era
en tierra de nadie el estado no tenía
presencia allí y cuando tenemos un
presidente que ha tomado la decisión de
dar una lucha frontal contra estas
estructuras criminales por supuesto toda
acción tiene una reacción y es lo que
hemos visto no solamente en los centros
penitenciarios sino penosamente se ha
ido hacia ciudades como guayaquil
esmeraldas ciudades portuarias donde se
están disputando precisamente las rutas
de narcotráfico hacia la región y bueno
previamente me hablaba de la importancia
de esta cooperación entre todos los
países y hay un país muy importante que
es vecino colombia está próximo a tener
elecciones con quién se sentiría más
cómodo trabajando el gobierno con de los
dos candidatos petro
con quien el pueblo colombiano decida y
lo tenemos que decir con esa claridad y
franqueza
ecuador y colombia tienen una tradición
muy importante de una relación amistosa
y esperamos que estas elecciones en
segunda vuelta sean limpias en
democráticas sean transparentes el
pueblo colombiano sabrá elegir lo mejor
para su futuro y ecuador estará
dispuesto a cooperar
precisamente en estos desafíos
y retos que tenemos en conjunto con
quien quede electo canciller juan carlos
holguín muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
para france24 muchísimas gracias a
ustedes y un saludo a todos y gracias a
ustedes por favor permanezcan en
sintonía viendo france24 puntocom